I'm going
the time
I belong
Oh
ow
hey wastelanders I'm Dave and I for one
welcome our new robot overlords and so
can you with this week's model a week
the cast synth armors and uniforms
standalone mega pack mod Oh a mouthful
this mod adds a possibility to craft
standalone synth armor and uniforms
currently loaded with over 120 armor
variations and at least 20 different
variations for synth uniforms complete
with unique 3d effects high-res textures
and their caste system which allows
chrome and color reflection effects to
give the armor different spectrums of
color cast stands for chrome area
selection technique a texturing
technique which allows the creator to
select the color of the reflection the
strength of the reflection and where it
appears on the model this modpack
created by mare attacker and echoes five
six five sixty creates a whole
underground bunkers worth of institute
based attire not only looking incredible
but also having the levels of
customization that you've come to expect
from all the game's default armors to
dress up like a cybernetic supermodel
you'll have to take all your new synth
gear over to your armored bench but the
mod authors are currently working on
implementing the suits on to enemy npcs
so you can see the wonderful work dotted
around Boston but for now take pride in
having a piece of kit as unique as you
are there is an awesome amount of detail
put into every piece in this collection
you've got 4k textures for armor and 2k
textures for helmets so you can be just
there Richie is little synth at the ball
the chrome details reflections and
colors also really make your newson
thread stand out from all the other
grubby rubbish you have filling up a
trunk back in sanctuary for those of you
who enjoy wandering the ruins of Boston
roleplay style you can pair this set
with your favorite laser based Institute
weaponry and roam the wastelands
avoiding the Brotherhood and kidnapping
Diamond City residents if you want the
synthetic humanoid look you can grab
this mod from the fallout mod Nexus
using the link below and after you've
fully assimilated yourself into your new
role of synthetic human come back and
let us know just what you thought of the
mod and if you have any mods you'd like
to see featured tweet the matters with a
hashtag GS fallout ivan dave and you can
find me on twitter at a regular dave and
until next episode stay safe out there
wasteland
you